so that that might be a problem okay
ready
all right so can they see us can they
hear us that's all i need to know all
right good
we're live folks it's good to be on with
you today we have a special
guest with us my brother here matthew
sapala a former marine who is now the
chief distribution officer php agency
which is absolutely no pressure but i'm
excited to have you
here on the podcast we got our buddy
here
adam sosnick back fellas we have a lot
to cover today
uh obviously what makes it special about
today's podcast today's on 9 11 which
we'll spend some time talking about that
here in a minute
on where uh all of us were out on 911.
i'd be curious to know this
obviously we know where many uh we know
where kai was at we know where
sam was at you know
fetuses 9 11 01 no not yet you were
three years old but uh some of them
possibly fetuses
so let me share with you we've got to
cover with you here today uh if you're
watching this uh press the thumbs up if
you're here with us
uh share the uh podcast um if you're on
with us here
we got a lot of topics one of them is a
documentary i just recently watched that
i want to share with you which
accidentally one of my friends robert
ends up sending this to me in the middle
of the night and i'm looking at the same
we just talked about this on the podcast
he says it's crazy because i didn't even
watch the podcast today
and it was talked about that's what's
crazy about the timing of this
documentary he sent
which we'll talk about in a minute here
uh uh some updates about goldman sachs
but what they're predicting with the gdp
i think it's important for most of us to
want to know this
the the the the merger that was supposed
to take place between
tiffany's and louis vuitton is not
looking too good
amazon hires an interesting ex-nsa
spy chief to work with them
netflix culture because of reed hastings
name coming up a lot lately twitter is
trying to sublease their space in san
francisco
so twitter jack dorsey and netflix reed
hastings have
complete opposite philosophies on work
environment we'll talk about that
and then citigroup hires their new
latest female board challenge
us firms add a black director to board
within 12 months you even saw kanye west
today
messaging saying i i'm not on the board
seat of adidas
and i'm not on the board seat of gap and
i wonder how is kanye west not on the
board seat of adidas that's a very valid
point on why you wouldn't put the guy
selling those
shoes you probably want to have his
perspective there
then some things with tick-tock then you
got uh germany putting pressure on
russia hacking taking place in election
with russia china and iran
and then uh rental properties in
manhattan which are tough to fi are easy
to find right now for
for a specific reason but let's first
talk about 911 let's get right into 911
so
uh if you're listening to this i'm
curious where were you on 9 11 but more
curious about you guys matt where were
you
on 9 11. i was in uniform i was uh i
just uh got out of the marine corps
and i i enlisted with the illinois
national guard so i was a
crew chief on a blackhawk and i was on
my way to the base i just dropped off my
son that's cool
i think reuben was uh in fourth or fifth
grade just dropped them
just dropped them off at school and they
called me hey so paul hurry up get in
here
what's going on uh somebody flew a plane
into the uh twin towers
why would why would somebody fly a
cessna there was a pilot lost
that's what i was thinking i thought it
was a small wow that's right cessna huh
yeah i was like that was assessed
that was a pilot that pilot airy got
lost and maybe it was
cloudy that day and boom twin towers so
i i get into the ready room
we're we're all there because we're all
kind of looking at the tv looking all
weird at the tv like okay a lot of smoke
is coming out the buildings
i said that just can't be assessed now i
mean what is the smoking next thing you
know
boom the second aircraft i'm like
what what are we watching here guys is
this uh is this die hard are you guys
watching die hard
i thought it was you're really having a
really good yeah and everybody was just
looking at the tv
in shock our mouths are starting to drop
quiet
quiet guys we're being freaking attacked
holy [ __ ] so we're we're you know we're
gearing up yep and uh we're in uniform
ready
we're to do a training mission i said
this about to go from a training mission
to
either rescue or a counter-attack
mission and we're about to fly we're
from chicago
so we're about to fly we're about to fly
to new york what's going on and so
right as soon as that as soon as that
happened they they grounded all the
aircraft non-essential
or or faa grounded everybody everybody
was
pissed a couple day a couple days later
day later that the new york national
guard was in our area they were with us
at the midway airport and uh they were
calling home they couldn't get ahold of
anybody
the cell towers were down it was just it
was just an odd scenario but uh
that was that was the day and then right
after right after we saw that on tv
i i went to the school i said listen uh
i don't know what's going on
uh so i picked up my kids the teachers
came out crying is there something going
to happen at the school is it something
that happens i'm just picking up my son
i'm just picking up my son i'm i'm
sending him back home so therefore i can
i can deploy if i need to but uh is it a
very eerie day
what a day for you and just just so
people understand who matt
is you had already been in desert storm
in the early 90s
right i mean talk about that a little
bit because this is almost a decade
later and now you might have to go back
again
that was and that was the biggest thing
that we were talking about so if we just
took care of business the first time we
were there
damn it never happened it never happened
it's the first thing i said you were
thinking that's what we're thinking of
so what do you mean what do you mean
take care of business because we're
there it was a four day five day war
in desert storms for our younger
audience out there this happened in
1991 yeah it happened under under the
first president bush
yep desert yep schwarzkopf george
yeah and so that's what we're saying if
we were just taking care of it but then
again we don't know we're
armchair quarterback and this whole
thing i know how deep it was but you
know we got in and got out and uh
you know and uh to see this happen and
again the reason and here's what we're
saying is young men
we want to fight these wars so therefore
our kids don't have to and here we are
17 18 years
still over there still freaking fighting
these wars yeah my story is not as
heroic as matt's i was a oh by far
well i mean you are you had already been
over there and you had served i was a
senior in college
um and you know getting ready to enter
the real world
that was you know where were you that
was 9 30
tuesday it was i was in my apartment in
tallahassee florida
at florida state university home of the
seminoles
i was living with uh like a duplex of
eight buddies yeah right like four on
one side and four and one
one side a black guy a french guy a
colombian guy a couple jewish guys
uh you know white uh like mag type of
guy
we had the most eclectic crew at florida
state
and i just remember one of our buddies
because this happened it
was it 8 a.m was it a little bit before
that yeah i mean right around then
yep and i remember we were all just kind
of getting ready to go to class
everyone's getting up and showered i
remember just all standing there
all different types of people diversity
and all just all americans
and being like what the actual
is happening right now yeah and no one
had any clue we weren't like oh it's an
attack it's freaking
a couple of saudi arabians like we had
no idea
i actually had class at 9am i'll never
forget
and i remember i went to school like
having no clue what was happening i get
to class they said no
class is cancelled like get out of here
and i was like okay
so i you take it like this like a campus
bus
and i remember sitting on the bus back
to my apartment
people of all different age shapes sizes
are sitting there like
what's going on what is going on who are
you who
can i trust you is it loud was it quiet
quiet you can hear a pin drop in a bus
when you ever hear that yeah so scary
stuff and obviously times have
completely
changed since that day i know you have a
crazy
so i was uh it was a day my second day
at morgan stanley dean witter
9 10 was my first day get out of here so
it's monday night
9 11 is uh tuesday morning 6 30 we're at
the
office uh dave kirby holds a meeting and
we're sitting there listening to him
and then one of the brokers from the
corner office screams turn on the
monitor turn on the monitor we turn on
the monitor to see what's going on and
you saw the first plane
and we watched the second plane hit live
and i'm in the ninth floor
of the new york life building today in
glendale
and uh later on we ended up having an
office in that same exact real thing
yeah i'm the same
life of an entrepreneur the exact life
of an entrepreneur building is where
morgan stanley was with new york life so
and i'm looking around everybody's
looking around the window
looking for planes first thing you're
looking for because morgan stanley's
headquarters got hit with 3 600
employees
that's what morgan stanley said and i'm
supposed to go to exactly 20 hours
so when that happens and the towers come
down i mean it was uh it was a mess they
sent us home
uh the following day brokers the market
uh they didn't even open up the market
they were so worried what's going to
happen the following day brokers didn't
even want to call their clients
they didn't want to call anybody uh and
you know what's even crazy when you
think about this while this whole event
takes place
and you know uh oh oh it's it's
you know who did this this person did
this it's linked to osama bin laden
here's who did all these stories that
are coming up
and i'm getting involved in the
financial industry i'm 6'4 i'm middle
eastern i'm here in golden
state i'm going out there it's like it's
constant uh you know where are you from
i'm from iran you're from iran
exactly perfect time to get into it
everybody left the marketplace everybody
in that office left the industry it was
like the worst time to be a part of it
but
you know the one thing i will tell you
when you when you see when 911 took
place the following here's the one thing
that we haven't seen this time around
and it's almost
as if a crisis is required to unify
the world when 9 11 happened
no one in new york looked at you as a
republican or a democrat
nobody looked at you as black or white
or latino everybody was just
where are your kids they're missing you
haven't seen him wait let's go find him
hey where's mayor where's your husband
all that there's a firefighter say
you know what i want to go to war i'm
willing to re-enlist i want to get into
it
there was this idea of unification right
versus you think about a crisis that
we're going through right now with covet
it's a divisive it's the division
we're divided with this crisis versus
being united
with 9 11 when 9 11 happened america was
united states of america when covet
happened america was a divided states of
america so
who was the hero in during 9 11 who was
the the beacon of hope freaking giuliani
yeah giuliani was the beacon of hope he
was and now he's blas
blasphemed as like this uh antichrist
people forget man people forget very
quickly what you do for them people
forget until you die in history books
you know
this a whole churchill story one of the
most hated guys there
but when you needed somebody to come in
and take care of business for you you
called churchill
and then years later after the guy's
dead then you really read about who this
guy
really was you know you almost got to
wait sometimes for some stories like
that for what rudy giuliani did to new
york but that you know that's the part
where
you hope that we experience a similar
thing where america becomes united
again today i just i just it's an it's a
different thing but again for everybody
out there
you know just go watch a video when you
see firefighters showing up and trying
to get people out and you hear how many
firefighters got hurt how many cops got
hurt
you will look at cops and firefighters
in a different way than the way they're
being painted right now the last six
months
it's a different ball game those were
heroes yep surely first responders
how different would 9 11 be if it
happened in a social media
live streaming see i don't think it has
to do with in a day of social media i'll
tell you in a different way
how different would it have been in a
divisive
media time that's the difference because
if it happens today everybody's pointing
fingers
it's it's and don't get me wrong back
then it's not like it wasn't divisive i
mean fahrenheit 911 whose fault was it
bush's job he did it
he's sitting there reading a kid book
you know you got all these other things
that was coming up don't forget it was
also the year after the
debacle of the 2000 election gore bush
gore which is in florida the chad
there was that going on as well but
somehow
we came together somehow we were united
this time around it's a little bit of a
different story
and you know you wonder why that is but
uh you know again for everybody that's
watching this
uh uh to everybody that served to
everybody that was there to all the
families i remember reading the people
magazine on the cover was mothers
with uh children these are moms whose
fathers husbands worked at the 911 at
the
world trade center and the planes hit
and the kids were born after 9 11.
to father that passed away so there's a
lot of emotion behind the story of 911
but the question before we move on
because i know we have a lot to talk
about
just on behalf of someone who has never
served i'm sitting here with a marine
and army um just respect for you guys
for serving for our nation
that's just number one number two as
someone who has never served i mean i
played
college football that's nothing in
comparison to what you guys have done
just number one salute number two why
don't you just talk to the audience
about what it's like
to serve and what that means for your
country because i genuinely want to know
i mean you must have a different
perspective
when you talk about 911 when you talk
about our country when you talk about
the flag
what it means to serve matt what would
you say you know we were talking to
general mattis a couple weeks ago during
our virtual convention
and uh one of his talks at the painting
his first talk at the pentagon
was on martin luther king day and he
says we need
one thing about the military it goes
back to its fundamental goes back to the
core beliefs
of the united states in terms of
fundamentals of how to get along with
other people
you know in the military even though we
have given uh patrick uniform
a hard time black white latino asian
i remember this african i was doing an
inspection
and i was going i was getting to know my
marines and says what's your name
so my name is mohimi abu dhabi salvador
what
abu dhabi salvador what okay
because he's salvador he's afraid i said
so where did the salvager come from
because you don't look anything like
this
you look very african yeah and the way
you're sounding the way you're boys and
the people from africa
from the from yes right right and so
this is uh well well sergeant i uh
i wanted to sound like an american so i
picked salvador
salvador that's it that's it you want to
speak you want to sound like an american
last name he picked salvador
that's an american wow not john not
johnson not william
not that david wow so you know so the
military we looked at one color
we looked at one color we looked at one
race what are you human what's the
biggest
thing that you have taken from the
military
biggest thing i've taken from the
military well you know so you know
self-sacrifice i would say
especially in a day we're thinking about
self-sacrifice then that's why you work
hard
i'm willing to sacrifice myself for your
life and the life of my brothers and my
sisters
then i probably am for myself wow and
that's why you got you got these guys
they are heroes i mean
we serve but the real heroes are the
ones in the towers the real heroes are
like the pat tillmans
that gave up at nfl career
right that they actually gave up their
life for this
as general maps would call this
experiment called america
by the way you you when you talked to
general mattis yeah what some news came
out about mattis yesterday right yeah
because of this whole you know trump
talking about you know the coven other
stuff and so the same
um the same author said oh by the way i
also had some
some conversations with with general
mattis that uh
north korea uh they're about to launch
the military you know the the nuclear
missiles whatever
and and general matters is at the ready
you know you got to figure
general mattis has been around not only
the marine corps the united states
military but around the world
galvanizing relationships and building
relationships so he was really worried
about you know north korea trying to get
some real attention and this is one this
is just yesterday uh it was just
yesterday about stuff that was done in
when he was a
uh secretary of defense right he was
ready for it he was raised
the story came out yesterday yeah yeah i
mean you you you think about the
uh uh mattis i mean when uh matt did the
interview were you in the room
yeah it was one of the most ridiculous
interviews i've seen
uh profound uh shout out to matt you
know you for how you did it that was
just yeah just for the record for our
viewers
matt interviews and it was powerful to
see that taking place
with the interview by the way general
mattis has some of the most famous lines
ever doesn't he oh yeah have you have
you read some of his lines have you read
it give me give me some of the
highlights
pull up pull up matters of famous
matters lines which you you got to love
this guy
famous general mattis line he's a modern
day chuck norris yeah there you go just
tap right there shout out to kai for
spelling it correctly oh
he almost had it yeah he's so so go
right there
i go up let's see which ones comes up uh
it's quite fun to shoot them you know
it's a hell of a hoot it's a it's fun to
shoot people this is what he said in
2005 okay
there are some [ __ ] in the world
that just need to be shot okay that's
true i come in peace
i didn't bring artillery but i'm
pleading with you with tears in my eyes
if you with me i will kill you all
be polite be professional but have a
plan to kill everybody you meet
there are some people you think some
people who think you have to hate them
in order to shoot them i don't think you
do i mean
this is this is a pretty edgy guy
okay yeah yeah and he chose not to get
married
and have kids because he married his
career
the warrior monk they called him because
he dedicated himself to war 45
44 can we read the last few quotes
because if you only read the first five
you think this guy's a complete maniac
he actually is
a brainiac if you will eight and nine go
ahead read it adam if he
i get a lot of credit these days for
things i never did you know
it's funny that he said that because
when i i thanked him for
this interview yeah interviewing he said
no i thank you for marines like you
yeah sarge like you i built my career on
the backbone that did a lot of work that
made me look good that's what he said
and the last one engage your brain
before you engage your weapon
yeah engage your brain yeah before you
engage your weapon so yesterday we had a
girl come in here
to uh help 15 people get a license to
carry yes okay
and it was so surprising when we send
the email to our employees to see who
was going to participate
you had some people that brought their
entire family like one of our guys
brought his mom you know hey we want to
get a license everybody's carrying this
and by the way she was so good i
wouldn't mind bringing her back to bring
him to the podcast because of the way
she was telling the story
oh she was impeccable wow on the way she
told the first 30 minutes on the way she
expressed like
explain license to carrie on what
happened to her her story of cr having a
license to carry
you know while i'm reading some of this
stuff and she would talk about engage
your brain before engage the weapon
uh she had a lot of good things to say
so can i make a note of it we may want
to bring her up to the podcast so
all right so there's general mattis
right there so we've covered a lot you
asked about military for me military
what it did for me was
i went in because i couldn't wait to
leave glendale california
i was working at a very uh a big four
prestigious
uh uh a burger company called burger
king
that's the big one it's the big four i
was at a big four though you have to
call it a big for burger king
yeah so so i'm working over there with
my friends davine
baharians and kogan alaverian and we're
working over there
and uh uh you know i just said i got to
figure out what i want to do my life one
day i'll go to the recruiting station i
joined the army
i go in i go to fort jackson i go to
fort campbell kentucky
hunter first airborne to me when i went
in it was
gi bill you're gonna have fun uniform
getaway
and then i go on april 15th and then
fourth of july hits
and i'm in south carolina for jackson
and fourth of july the entire time is
what barbecue having fun all this other
stuff
then you go and you celebrate fourth of
july in
uniform on you know in the
military unit you know fort jackson and
then you watch
you know kernels and tears you you watch
you know captains and tears you watch
sergeant majors in tears
and you're asking why are you in tears
do you realize what do you realize what
it took for us of our freedom
and you listen to the same song that
everybody's heard before man it got me
so
emotional then we get to our unit and i
never forget this when i got to hunter
first they said there's a movie coming
out
that has to do about your unit and you
are the first to watch it before the
public sees it and we're like okay cool
what's this movie so we're going to the
auditorium we go into the auditorium
and the movie starts you know what the
movie was saving a private ride wow
let me tell you buddy we watched saving
private ryan with 600 of us
you were at 600 people were ready to go
to battle after watching this movie big
guys in emotions tears
hugging each other let's go nobody
messes with us it was intense 1998 what
year was 1997 is when i got to my so
it's late 97 i would say
you know saving private ryan probably
came out somewhere late 1997. yeah
and then you go to the unit you you
learn what it is to sleep four hours a
night you learn what it is to work your
tail off you learn what it is to
you know have to go out there in the mud
in the field sleep all this other stuff
i it was one of the best decisions i
ever made in my life to join
if somebody's listening to this you're
18 you're undecided what you want to do
with your life
military may not be a bad option when
you watch that opening scene he talked
about self-sacrifice yeah right and i
want to know what your number one
takeaway was
in general but when you talk about
self-sacrifice and if you have not seen
saving private opening scenes is
cheese guys legit ridiculous yes i mean
you're you're about to serve for america
yeah you're talking about you have
served
opening scene you're storming storming
the beaches of normandy trying to take
down the nazis
half the platoon the platoon was just
clipped yeah done blown away 75
tom hanks can't hear he's way what did
that do to you
i mean you think you you think you're
tough until you see that you're like
okay how are you going to be reacting to
that what kind of
time do you have to be thinking about
any of this stuff you know what is your
reaction mode boom
the moment that thing goes down you
could be done your life is over
yeah it's a very uh it's it's uh it's
emotional because you know yesterday the
girl was saying how
you know uh uh i don't know who asked
the question if you're in the car oh
one of the guys asked a question he says
my brother was driving and
three guys pulled up to him next to him
in a car on the freeway and they start
shooting up in a paintball
paintball yeah paintball but you know
it's still your word like a guy takes
out a gun
he says he asked her is it legal if
somebody has a license to carry to take
out the gun and shoot the car
she says first of all you're not gonna
hit the car you're gonna miss the car
okay you're not gonna hit it she said
second of all
you can think how you're gonna react in
those moments you will never know
until you are in those moments what she
does for a living
is she chases human traffickers that's
what she does for them she works with
jobs
that's what she does for a living by the
way would you call her a badass kai
would you say she's a qualified badass
she's teaching the class she's got a
piece right here she's fully locked you
know
lock and load she's ready for it and uh
you know when you ask the question about
what you do when you go there
anybody can say let me tell you you know
i'm going to do this
you have no idea when you see that yeah
you can't train for that how do you
train for that when you open up these
are 18 19 year old kids yeah that have
to have a quick reaction to it
i don't know what are your thoughts when
you when you see that it's fine because
you're from l.a right
so i remember diaz diaz if you're
listening platoon 27.3 echo company
second battalion come on baby diaz big
gang banger
diaz right gangbangers like which he is
uh not uh he's a recruit okay i was like
i was in boot camp with i was in boot
camp different deals okay different dx
because we have a ds as well he's a big
guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a different
ds so uh so he he's a big big thug and
uh
as soon as he got to that gas chamber to
practice
how you would react in a gas chamber on
a c6 gas cs
uh riot gas he was crying like a baby in
the corner straight up straight right
so you know you never know until people
are putting those
positions they confront all day long
front all day long and people the least
that you least expect
to be strong and courageous in the
moment it's surprising when that happens
you learn you learn a lot about people
uh when when something happens to them
to wrap this up pat yes so move on what
was your biggest takeaway from the
military he said self-sacrifice what was
it
i just wouldn't be who i am today if it
wasn't for the military to me
the camaraderie you cannot explain the
level of camaraderie
you know uh last night we went to have a
cigar right
and uh we went to your spot chambers
very soon so we go to chamberlain's and
we're sitting here in cigars okay
and i'm no longer obviously the ceo of
the company matt is not the cdo but
when when i got out of the military and
i decided to go into sales
everything i ever did i wanted to have
that element of camaraderie because it's
tough to explain
yeah and and you know when you look at
the netflix culture
one thing about the netflix culture you
read through it if you've never read
this
yeah well we have we'll cover this here
in a minute cool when you go through a
culture
that you create there were people that
joined the military
that hated the culture i have a friend
of mine that i went to high school with
he went to a completely different unit
he went to alaska and he went to
anchorage
uh fort wainwright i don't know if you
know fort wayne right in alaska
he hated the military when he got out
everything he said was bad about the
military right
i have friends who went in the military
couldn't stand it oh my gosh it's
terrible they do this they do that to
you it was
horrible right i have friends who have
worked at netflix
who said i hated working on netflix i
know people who worked at amazon
who hated working at amazon i know
people that worked at apple
under steve jobs regime and they
couldn't stand working on something like
that
but if you go in if you like that
you know team camaraderie call out
challenging pushing humor laughter
teamwork teamwork i got your back let's
if you like that yeah you would love the
military so all of that we brought out
to what we did every business ever and
every office i've ever ran
the the culture of it's been going back
to what we had
at 326 engineers at hunter first
airborne division air assault when we
served at that unit
we had a unit we had a group it was
myself bradford gutierrez it was a group
of us
klingerman it was it was a group of us
that you couldn't mcelroy you couldn't
separate this group it was a certain
level of camaraderie you sat together
you sat at the chow hall to get
everything you did you were brothers
right
so if you tell me what you take away
from the military
i cannot describe you the high you get
from the camaraderie
in the military and i you know you miss
it but you hope to create it in another
environment that you work in
obviously that's exactly what we've done
i was going to say when you were
describing that that sounds exactly what
you've built at php yeah that's the
what's the longest run individually
you've ever been on if you went out to
go run
yeah for a distance just to go out and
jog before military was the longest
you've ever before the military before
the military
to the 7-eleven
right and next you know you're in boot
camp yeah you're in formation next year
running miles
yeah did you ever think you could run
miles like that no i was not a long
distance runner that'd be the thing
yeah there'd be anything i'm like we got
to run three miles we've got to run five
miles we're gonna
we gotta march 26 miles i'll never do
this alone
but amongst the unit amongst comrade
team camaraderie
uh for your brothers man let's hump it
out that's awesome
yes yes so for anyone out there our
younger audience out there considering
going to the military 100 a good
decision
a 100 good decision no because if you
are decided on what you want to do
no you don't need the military but if
you if you're lost if you have no clue
what you're doing with your life and you
want to have an environment that's going
to teach you discipline toughness
independence by yourself washing your
clothes cleaning your
place somebody challenging you that
maybe your parents cannot do because
you're emotionally attached to your
parents
may not be a bad idea you got to realize
trump went to a military academy as a
kid because
he even talks about he was a difficult
kid growing up right so his father fred
sent him to military academy he kind of
straightened him out
you know and uh he told the story he
says back then
when it was about discipline discipline
was they could he hit you back then when
he went to military academy
was it it was in the pc environment
today no not today when he went i mean
you've got to realize he's 74 right now
so when he went
say he was 11 12 years old what is that
62 years ago
what's 62 years ago it's 1960s
1958 is when he went to military i mean
that's
that's a completely different america
than what it is different world complete
you could get away with a lot of stuff
but i think if somebody's undecided what
they want to do with their lives and
they want to go see the world you're
going to see the world you're going to
have great opportunities
and uh you know i mean look shout out to
bradford brad for my buddy who's
got a channel he's killing it i'm so
proud of him
uh for what he's doing this guy goes in
and he doesn't just go in and do
you know special forces he decides to go
20 years and takes it to a whole
different level some of the projects
that he's done
i can't even talk about on on out of
respect to him but uh
you got some people that go in and turn
it into a life
and it's not about money because you
don't make a lot of money you make two
three thousand dollars a month i
remember this guy's story you don't make
a lot
but uh yeah so so that's let's let that
that's uh
that's how that's it about military
salute to you two
military veterans and salute to our
military everybody else
if you're a veteran post below if you're
a veteran we salute you
if you are a veteran we salute you by
the way let me bring up this josh topic
a lot of people are asking about josh
uh let me just address it here once
everybody understands josh came out here
uh he was doing some digital marketing
for us and it
uh uh was going good when he wasn't i
think he was in arizona working for us
and then him and i had a conversation
together
about him coming out here and i decided
to hire him because of his abilities to
be creative and come up with great
campaigns
we hired him on board as a president of
eyetainment six weeks later it didn't
work out i asked him i don't think this
is going to work out we went a different
direction
we wished him nothing but the best uh on
uh
on what his endeavors are going to be
but it didn't work out
and you know when you think about the
david podcast here what we're doing
couple things you guys got to keep in
mind the people that are watching this
i created this podcast for one reason
let me explain to you what this is
i have a lot of friends that i want to
introduce
to the world that i want to sit down and
have a conversation with like last night
when we were out was a podcast if you
think about it
last night was a podcast last night was
absolutely a podcast because we sat
there we're telling stories
you know hey what do you think about
this what do you think like i got i got
a list of 50 friends that i want to
invite to be on this show you know these
50 friends i don't invite to be on this
show
it's to sit down and have many different
stories i mean we had tom zenner
uh the last two mattis here uh we had
rapper tony we've had josh we've had
you we've had ray crockett expect to see
another 50 100 friends that are gonna be
here
of people that i enjoy talking to these
are people that i enjoy talking to
and many of you guys for years kept
saying pat you got to start a podcast
you got to start a podcast you got to
start a podcast
why do i need to start a podcast i
remember when people say you got to
start a vlog i'm like oh my god i
cannot stand doing vlogs
i cannot stand doing vlogs non-stop
cameras following you watching every
single thing you're doing
yeah but podcasts are a little bit
different because you can sit there and
have uh opinions about certain things
and uh
you know uh and kind of share your
thoughts and so the viewer said pat we
love to have the
podcast type of a format and obviously
now we're doing that so let's talk about
culture is that fair we talk about
culture let's talk about culture so we
got netflix
kai when did when did reed hastings
write this what's the timeline when he
wrote this
okay can you pull up when he wrote this
so years ago
reid hastings decides to write
his culture okay he decides to write out
his culture on
how he wants to build out netflix by the
way
if you've not seen this if you've not
seen
this this is a must read
culture deck of netflix i don't know if
you've gone through this or not
it's a hundred and twenty something
pages looks like a powerpoint of
something it's pretty much what it is
it's 120 something pages
he wrote this in 2009 so it says post
dvds
it's post dvds yes he writes this in
and the whole idea is this is what we
stand for okay this is what we stand for
by the way the last six months we've
been spending time coming up with our
own culture for what we were doing here
with the company both for the field
and home office but he writes this
then he puts it online and leaves it
public
do you know how many views this thing
gets wow can you tell us how many views
this thing gets
pull up and and type in netflix culture
deck
how many people went to visit how many
people
saw the netflix
culture deck let's see eleven and a half
million people have viewed this culture
wow can you imagine people say oh my
video went viral
okay yeah my my podcast went viral
that's just on his slideshow account by
the way my my
i sold a million copies of my book no no
11 and a half million people read my
culture deck
for free for free how does a culture
they go viral but that's exactly what he
did
okay i had the opportunity to interview
his chief uh uh uh human resources human
resources
chief talent officer uh patty mccord
right she wrote a book called
uh impossible i don't know what the i
think was called impossible
i had her on the vault uh conference
last year and i had her come down
and i interviewed it because i wanted to
find out what is the netflix culture and
the kind of you know way they work over
there right
and listening to her you would think
it's a whole different company
powerful is what the book is called so
here's netflix
and here is uh uh uh what do you call it
uh uh
twitter let's kind of go through this
together so netflix culture
we manage on the edge of chaos okay
if you think of the last 300 years we've
had factories providing enormous
economic value and so a lot of our
society has the factory as the model of
the organization very top-down very
processed very efficient
but it's not the right way to run a
creative organization an organization
that needs new ideas needs to be able to
make mistakes
netflix employees love working here it's
so fun because people feel the trust
openness of the culture information
sharing and because they've
got incredible colleagues and so they
got a lot
they got to do a lot okay so netflix is
not for everyone
he says netflix is for people who are
learning machines
machines a lot of people don't like to
be called machines but he says no you
are a learning
machine if you work here best machine
they just love absorbing new
ideas and new experiences and are
willing to make mistakes to figure
things out
and it's those kinds of self-motivated
learners
that do so well at netflix
and then he says netflix ceo reed
hastings
is not a fan of working from home and
wants his employees back
at the office 12 hours after a vaccine
is approved yes
you get the vaccine take the shot back
to work get back to work is what he
wants
now jack dorsey is the complete opposite
sure
twitter is trying to sublease parts of
the san francisco headquarters after
telling employees they can work from
home forever
ceo jack torchy has repeatedly said that
having a decentralized workforce has
been the goal for several years
subleasing over a hundred thousand
square feet of office space includes
over 878 workstations
available up to five years their office
spans over eight hundred thousand square
feet in total
they are now sublisting some of their
space shoot let me get some of that
furniture yeah
but i think but i think the point here
is you got netflix
their culture is you need to be at the
office like you know they have a
what's the one line you said about work
he says uh uh uh severance package
what's the one like yeah
adequate adequate effort here at netflix
gets you a generous
severance package adequate effort at
netflix gets you a generous severance
package
so it's not like you're working there oh
i can take as much vacation i want i can
just kick it relax all this other stuff
no no you better deliver on your product
if you don't you're fired sure okay
but you know twitter is a little bit
different work for him
you know netflix saying no no you got to
be at the office
who's right working from home or working
from the office who is who has
innovated the most over time has it been
netflix or has it been twitter
i think it's netflix of course you know
why because there's connection there's
connection this podcast isn't done
virtual over zoom
this podcast is done here in person uh
support
in person why because you can't replace
high tech or high touch with high tech
you know there's there's a certain
feeling the the relationship you know
the the
even though we had a great virtual event
two weeks ago the reason why we sold so
many tickets to our regional events like
we
broke records and selling tickets our
regional events january february because
everybody's looking forward to
connecting in person it was the biggest
amount of text we ever saw to the next
event after leaving
our our current event why because people
are looking tonight people were dying to
connect people were like
you know this pattern everybody's been
separated we had people at our house
people remote offices were connecting
and they felt like they were
virtual but there's nothing like being
together
in a room there's nothing like yeah i
mean church is great
but man it's nothing like being in a
church and feeling the holy spirit move
in the room versus through a computer or
tv adam what do you think i agree with
matt uh for sure um i will say that
there is something magical
about not having to leave your house um
and get everything you want to get done
and accomplish
all your goals and your dreams and your
visions in your pjs there's something
dope about that
uh but so i like the 80 20 approach 80
of the time get your ass into an office
be a part of a culture but 20
of the time hey man maybe you take
fridays off maybe you know like you're
talking to somebody
that has not gone other than being here
a ridiculous amount of hours a week i
haven't been in an office in
seven years yeah and my numbers have
gone up every year or else
the ceo of my company would put my ass
back in the office so this is the
you know i highlight a bunch of
different things this is the last thing
that uh
our friend reed hastings he said and
those kind of self-motivated
learners that do so well if you're
self-motivated you don't need somebody
to say rah-rah says
and you can do it yourself yeah you can
work from anywhere you can work from the
moon
if that's if that's what it'll take to
get the job done but there's a lot of
people that are not self-motivated that
need to come to an office
that need to be a part of the culture so
yeah um
i don't think creativity doesn't come
from the head creativity comes from the
heart
it's got it's got to come from heart
power it can't come from
yes it's it's illogical but if you want
to be creative you want to
develop you want to innovate i think you
need to be connected and
what we're learning from this lockdown
is pandemic is like there's a
i believe there's a combination there's
a combination of virtual there's a
combination but there's a discipline
behind not you know staying at home
a refrigerator uh espn if they're sports
sound whatever kids
distractions kids distraction i think
there's a huge value for your company
you want to grow
and innovate you got to be present
together the beauty
is that due to technology were even
able to have this conversation sure
think about you know
five years ago even yeah ten years ago
covet happens how's your virtue how's
your uh
annual event looking at that point it's
cancelled straight up well that other
service we used
yeah that remember that oh gosh
through the wall babe if you're
listening to this it comes patrick a
phone too i threw my phone i threw my
five guys
but you guys put together an amazing
virtual event matt interviewed general
mattis our friend ricky interviewed
pitbull uh i was a guy tom that
interviewed uh
trey gowdy trey gowdy very good very
good virtually
it was very good very good but there's
something magical about that that's
awesome that's dope technology
technology amazing
but like you said nothing takes the
place of just what's up man how you
doing even even trey gowdy said hey next
time i look forward to doing this in
person
awesome connection it's not a bad plan b
so so let's talk about that so let's
talk about uh
working from home or working from an
office so to me
i've recruited a lot of people in my
career
uh i've recruited a lot of people that
didn't fit my culture
over my career i've recruited people
that do well under pressure
i've recruited people that don't do well
under pressure i've recruited people
that
do well working with their wives i've
recruited people that don't do well
working with their
wives right i've recruited people that
um
you know are hard working hard
charging constantly going but but the
one thing i will tell you is
i've seen that people that are solo
people there are people that are team
people
you got the solo you got the team it's
like sports
you got kids that want to play tennis
you got kids that like playing golf
yeah you got kids i like playing like
swimming why because
it's wrestling it's operating it's me i
control my failure and success and they
like it 100
yeah it's like hey i want to be an
attorney okay
i want to be an accountant i want to be
a sales
person i want to be a i want
one person surgeon i want to be this
right
and then there's those that are team now
here's what typically happens to team
people team people have been team people
for their entire lives okay
these are people that want to be around
others these are people that enjoy
company
these are people that don't want to go
to the movies by themselves they're
going to call and say what are you doing
let's go
watch them hey these are people that hey
you let's go play basketball together
you know
the guy that always knew how to put
let's go to the club five of you roll up
there's this one guy that hey i don't
want to go it's like the guy that would
concert bro get out of your bed
10 o'clock let's go oh man i'm tired bro
you're 20 years old you've got plenty of
video games now
everybody has that one friend right that
wants to be the team guy
you know what typically happens with
solo people here's what happens with
solo people
solo people some early some later
solo people eventually get to a point in
their lives where they have to make a
decision
and here's what solo people have to make
a decision they have to make a decision
whether
i want to do it all by myself because
i'm
capped being solo yeah solo's got a cap
yep because you can't take over the
world by yourself your cap
team people are not limited yeah solo
people eventually when they get to that
point and make a decision to go
work on a team they need a team around
them they tend to
take their lives and their game to the
next level what's my point i'm making to
hear
working from home is solo working from
home is not necessarily a team thing
working from an office environment
together it's a whole team situation
that you have there
you know you you kind of get a chance to
sit down and even right here there's a
certain dynamic going on here yeah
i had a chance to meet his family last
night i wouldn't meet his friends
who brought the whole family to his
family louise yeah
we're working over here you know uh sam
and i had him
he took care of me a couple of times i
said mario gotta i like the way this guy
takes care of us he's class he's
like a concierge service at the highest
level right
you sit there i've had how many times
have i spoken to your mom kai how many
times have your mom and i have
conversations together
i talked to his mom and i got i know it
sounds weird but i'm telling him his
mom's happily married and i'm happily
married
but i've talked to kai's mom multiple
times and you said you're like hey
family what's up
but if it's not here and you're walking
past the desk there isn't that
opportunity to say
hey how you doing because it's at home
so that deep
additional connection of layers doesn't
happen
if it's not face to face in a group but
doesn't it always just come back to
culture you've created and
it works culture yeah it works it's a
culture but
nobody emotionally gets attached to
something that they work from home
you can't get attached to something that
could work from home emotionally yeah
and typically when people want to run
through a wall for a company or a
message or an organization
it's got to be in a group environment so
that's the thing when it comes down to
uh this part so now let's talk about new
york i mean we've been taking a lot of
shots out of california let's give new
york sometime because
real quick can i take a quick break
speaking of uh teamwork from home can i
make a quick wish to absolutely can you
please do so yes
sweetheart if you're watching this my
wife was born at 9 11.
wow yeah sheena so babe if you're
watching this uh from the bet david show
we wish you a happy happy birthday uh
welcome to your 21 year old birthday
again
can't believe this is maybe your second
time celebrating your 21st birthday
again but uh yeah she's uh she's uh
she's uh excited about this day we have
barbie playing tonight but babe love you
happy birthday here on 9 11.
and congratulations to sheena for being
the chairman of the board yeah you know
my biggest woman of the board of the
field you know it's amazing
uh uh for her to go from where she was
at both of you guys to where you are
today
so okay so let's talk about manhattan uh
yes sheena happy birthday to you i got
something special coming your way so
so be prepared for it people with your
surprises
so manhattan manhattan
manhattan new york okay had a record
15 025 empty
apartments in august ouch let me say
this one more time manhattan had a
record of 15
025 empty apartments
in august the borough vacancy rate rose
above 5
for the first time ever according to a
report from real estate
from douglas element an appraiser miller
samuel it was the highest level in the
report's 14-year history during which
manhattan's vacancy rate
has fluctuated between one and a half
percent
to two and a half percent guys let me
let me say this to you to go from one
and a half to two and a half
to five percent is double this is not a
small number here
over the past four months the rate has
made a steady and steep rise hitting a
record
each month adam you see the stats with
new york
15 025 empty apartments in august
5 vacancy for the first time what do you
think about this
you know if you asked me um
in february so every summer i tend to
get out of my
born and raised in miami i live in miami
i can work remote if you ask
so every summer i try to go someplace
different i travel what have you
if you asked me this february
pre-covered
what my summer plans would be i'd say
there's a 100 chance i'll be in new york
chillin i love new york city you know
rent an apartment for a month or two
um i love it i love just i put on some
headphones and i just walk all around
the city there's nothing like it in
manhattan
in manhattan it's it's it's the bump um
fast forward um um um in in the second
city closest to new york city addison
texas is nothing more bad
i mean it it just shows what covett has
done it has taken
the life out of new york city i mean
think about why you live in new york
city think about why you pay a premium
to live in new york city and new york
city number two
most expensive place to rent number one
san francisco median rent in new york
for a one bedroom
seven hundred square feet three thousand
dollars right three thousand believable
national average you're looking at
fourteen hundred bucks so double and
then if you're talking that's median
actually average actually
closer to 4 000. but you pay a premium
for all the
fun and amazing stuff you can do in new
york the museums the parks
the culture but if you can't do that
and you're sitting at home why the hell
are you paying three four grand or if
not more
to sit in your apartment yeah there's no
point yeah
so you pay a premium premium for
fun and lifestyle but if there's no fun
and lifestyle and you're just sitting at
home
and you can work virtual it's actually a
very good point you're making why would
you ever live in new york at this point
so
so deep benefit that new york offers
you're now
not getting so why am i paying that kind
of money to be in new york
very valuable it's the point of new york
very valid point very valuable what do
you think about that yeah the same thing
too is
back to culture yeah that was the that's
the culture of manhattan the
connections and the whole cycle if if
businesses aren't operating
to create the jobs and the jobs for
people to make money
people to spend the money yep so
business can still thrive
so it doesn't receive the money so that
whole cycle is not happening right now
so if the cycle is not happening
this is exposing this is exposing that
that that vacancy so so this is the
question to ask so when you think about
right now with
nfl game yesterday we were watching
deshaun watson against uh
pat mahomes right shout out to uh uh
mahomes for
you know coming out yeah just doing what
he does and
then deshawn watson you know he he lost
a very good receiver we hope he gets
something back because that guy's a
talented guy but
you know you're watching the game and
they have some fans there they were
expecting 17 000 people in kc yeah a lot
of these nfl stadiums they're not
selling any tickets
right but casey said yes so 17 000
people showed up
to the game right give or take they
usually have what 70 000 they usually
have
60 70 000 people there right so you
watch the nba
the bubble right and you see what's
going on with the bubble
and you're watching some of these games
and people watching the games from their
what do you call it their screens then
you know their uh zoom and like okay
cool let me see how this is going to
work
the question you ask with sports is and
restaurants is the following
say because of kovid nba lost a million
fans that are watching it i'm just
throwing a number out there
the question you gotta ask is how many
are gonna come back
okay so if you watch football and you
watch and say i'm not interested like i
was before you gotta have the fans the
screaming the hollering oh you know the
richter scale on the sound
oh it's so loud right now seattle golan
you know what seattle's known to be one
of the loudest
oklahoma city is known as being one the
louder yeah now you don't have that
element right i mean if you're missing
that 12 minutes so
are you going to watch the game the same
way but the question becomes how many
are going to come back
i think the biggest thing with this
manhattan deal is the following
fine you're at five percent yes it's
scary
the question is how many are going to
come back right
that's the real question because if it
doesn't mayor de blasio needs to be
fired asap
and cuomo's got to get involved because
one of his mayors is screwing the whole
thing in new york
and coma's got to look at what things
he's doing to take some responsibility
and seeing what they need to change in
the state of new york to not be losing
people
and to gain people back because you
remember the whole conversation we had a
few weeks ago
where uh uh the whole thing was well you
know aoc
you know amazon why should we give you
tax breaks to come to new york city
why are we giving these billionaires tax
breaks because they're moving their
entire operation to a place that they're
not used to
and they're going to create 25 000 jobs
at an average salary of 150 000
for your city that you lost well now
that you're
losing an audience and your apartments
15 025 are empty do you want those
people back
so so cuomo has to sit there and worry
and say how many of these are gonna come
back
how many of them do we lose permanently
how many of them did we lose permanently
because i left california to go to
dallas i lost you you know what the plan
was when i
left to california to go to dallas to go
back to california
to go back to california but california
has lost me
california's las vegas all my friends
family everybody's in california
you can close my eyes put me in the car
open the window i can smell and tell you
what street we're on
i've driven on every single road in l.a
in california
i mean you can tell me take me anywhere
i know how to go to
any place because i've been all over
california all over right
so now i come here i'm lost every other
day okay
i just know how to get to the office and
the airport when i'm in texas these ways
are very different maybe
yeah exactly that's not a lot it's a
u-turn so so now you go to a different
place but that's a permanent
person you lost this is not a temporary
person a permanent person with jobs they
created jobs
you're okay losing temporary people for
example when hurricane happens in
florida where do people go
new york new york but it's temporary
yeah so florida doesn't care because
like listen after the hurricane right
they're coming back of course
when new orleans hurricane hit people
left permanent right
right right yeah so yeah new york place
is this a
permanent exodus or is this a temporary
one
because if it's permanent new york's
about to take a hit that we don't even
know the aftershock effects of this you
mentioned a few podcasts ago a bunch of
billionaires also
departed yes so not only the vacancies
are happening but you have job creators
and innovators 336 billion dollars of
wealth left that's a lot of money so
you know who's gonna have to do a lot of
cooking governor cuomo
come back to new york i'll cook you
dinner well you got cooking recruiting
about 15 16 000 people to cook you know
i get people that give me a hard time
and they say pat i cannot believe you
like that guy cuomo and you say good
things about cuomo he's not who you
think he is and all this other stuff
let me tell you what i've learned how to
do a lot of you guys say stuff about
adam okay
adam this adam that adam this let me
tell you
adam gets along with everybody okay
adam is homie adam is
chill he's thought i met adam eight
years ago
and when i met adam i'm like you know he
would always approach me i'm like i
don't know this guy
but i like this guy every single time
and then eventually
i'd see him once he's like hey you're
going yeah i'm going oh cool and then
we'd run into each other run into each
other right
so you know i just like this guy
politically
he can you know stand trump and he can't
stand this and maybe i'm going to be on
a different side when it comes down to
policies and all this other stuff but
the guy is cool
right adam's school you can call him soy
boy you can call him whatever you want
to call him
the only guy on the show that has a
nickname right soyboy i don't even have
a nickname you got a nickname
you're good no no soyboy's like madonna
some people have just a name like
madonna courtesy
how are we doing the point i'm trying to
make to you thank you valuetainers
better than tofu the point i'm trying to
make by the way you know what's funny is
a lot of people are saying you know what
i got to tell you i used to hate adam
but i love him that i hate the fact that
i have to say it
but you know you know thank you guys the
thing about the thing about cuomo is
i don't look at politics so the first
thing i look at is i say do i like this
guy
yeah it's how i judge people first thing
i do i like this guy
that's how people should operate at
first you say you know what i like this
guy who they are not what they are yeah
and then what's his belief system and
then
why does he believe in what he believes
in and then if it's
then okay you know what cool i totally
get why you believe in what you believe
in totally again i understand the reason
behind it right
but cuomo's got his uh job cut out for
him
and because he needs to have an
emergency meeting and figure out a way
to keep
by the way and i i just saw the stats
kai i don't know if you put it here or
not new york's going back to 25
opening oh there it is new york cuomo
announces indoor dining reopened to 25
capacity but experts say it's not enough
to save restaurants on wednesday new
york governor andrew como announced the
state would
open that up as of september 30th which
is end of this month most restaurants
operate a
on razor thin margins and barely break
eke out a profit even at 100 capacity
andrew
riggy the executive director new york
hospitality alliance the business told
business insider cuomo's announcement
came
after 300 restauranteurs filed a
class-action lawsuit against cuomo and
mayor de blasio seeking 2
billion dollar in damages and demanding
that restaurants be allowed to reopen
dining rooms
what the hell is 25 yeah it's nothing i
mean
how many waiters and waitresses do i get
at 25
it was 75 capacity of 75 they can only
see
12 guests that's not 25
by the way yeah and then they needed six
staff as well so they're eighteen
or they're counting the staff as part of
the twenty-five percent let me get this
straight
wait wait wait wait wait wait so if you
have 75 capacity
you can only have 12 guests plus six
staff 18 that's 75 72
70 that's pretty insane to be thinking
about what is 25
going to do to save these restaurant
businesses so the server's got to be the
host the bartender the
bus boy so therefore they can have more
tables to turn i mean we go to this one
restaurant greek restaurant in uh
by preston hollow we love this place
it's a hole in the wall but it's
phenomenal food they're dressing their
salad dressing because
it's got something in there that's
addictive i don't know what the heck
i'm telling you i love it and by the way
they make the best arnold palmer at this
place i'm an arnold schwarzenegger
75-25 90 10. it's the best arnold palmer
i've had in my life don't you dare get
that right
someone got this guy uh 90 lemonade 10
threw it in the guy's face we get out
damn sour thing
so it's actually true story so uh uh
so what's it called yeah so we go to
this place and one day
i noticed they're very busy i said
what's going on it's a greek restaurant
owned by a guy from ukraine
okay so it's funny the ukraine guys own
this greek restaurant and they kill it
they cook better than greeks do
okay so there's one waitress who is
serving all the tables because that's
what restaurant owners have to do today
yeah yeah
i can't have a lot of people being there
because i got to pay the money for them
so
you're sure i'm opening up to lose money
yeah 25
is open to lose money 50 is open to lose
money so
i i think this this pressure new york's
having is going to get to a whole
different level so
as much as they'd like to keep this
thing dragged out for a little longer to
help with the election
i think cuomo is going to eventually
cave in and realize he needs to
satisfy his citizens and the people of
new york and get things back to normal
maybe not fully you can still have the
mask stuff that's going on
but get it back to foley so we'll see
what happens ask our audience
how many of them are in new york i know
we asked our audience how many people
were in california yeah how many of you
are from new york and if you are in new
york
uh if you are in new york how are you
feeling about the restaurants opening up
at 25
by the way if you're watching this and
you're having a good time with just put
a thumbs up
share this i and hit the subscribe
button i think we're about to crash 2000
live in the next few minutes we're at
1781 but
you know uh so you know that's what you
got going on with new york and cuomo and
15 thousand apartments let me just say
one thing about these razor
thin margins um most restaurants operate
on
razor thin margins that's where you took
that from kai from this article
you know i did a i did a interview one
time for sales talks money on my show
i interviewed the number one hotelier
hospitality guy
in miami and he said that you know
think about a business that makes
four million dollars in gross sales as a
restaurant
he has to hope and pray that he can make
ten percent so
net net four hundred thousand dollars
and then after that he has to pay taxes
so you're talking about razor thin
margins here
your operating costs and everything
after that you gotta hope and pray for
i said that's the number he goes that's
90 is paid out 90
paid out so you were talking about
you're only at 25
capacity what a rough how do you operate
like that they wrote a rough business to
be in there but this is why it's
going to be cooking yeah coma's going to
be cooking but i think cuomo has
common sense but i do believe coma has
common sense because it's going to be a
trigger effect you did a poll
california or new york better place for
entrepreneurs
on twitter yes on 3100 votes yeah
new york california 50 50. 50 50. but on
instagram
51 000 votes california 59
new york 41 percent better for
entrepreneurs what's the difference what
do we got here well i mean people give
their arguments why they believe
california is better than new york
because the
uh new york is smaller more condensed
california's wider you can build that in
more different areas of california
northern california's got business
southern california's got business
central has some business so there's a
lot of different places so new york is
more
new york city it's very you don't hear
upstate buffalo you don't hear a lot of
that starting a business in albany yeah
i i don't know if i've heard that unless
if you're uh what's better
i'm sorry go ahead go ahead what's
better for taxes
new york is ahead of california so
california is the worst california's
50th worst
out of 50 states wow new york is 42nd
so if you had the choice of moving back
to california or moving to new york what
would you pick pbd
i would move to florida i love that
answer
options but i also want to say there's a
triggering effect here if you've got
this much
empty apartments you got restaurants
barely staying in business
360 billion dollars lost what what's
what's another industry in new york
that's about to implode
or have a set a major setback which is
those hotels and relationships
you know commercial real estate a lot of
these landlords going to have a
tough time paying that mortgage well
there's racial tax cdc now cdc announced
you can't evict anybody if they're not
paying the rent
until the end of the year cdc just
announced that anybody that's
renting if they have a loss of a job and
they're making less than 199 000
husband and wife together their rent
is forgiven until the end of the year
cdc came out with this part so you know
it's not a good time to be in commercial
temporary fix though yeah that's not a
good time to be in commercial real
estate right now it's a it's a very
complete uh very interesting time by the
way
portland becomes the first city to ban
the use of facial recognition technology
by government agency and private
entities in public spaces
let me read this one more time portland
becomes the first city to ban the use of
facial
recognition technology by government
agencies and private entities
in public spaces mayor ted wheeler
said during hearings that portlanders
should never be in fear of having their
rights
of privacy be exploited by either their
government or by a private institution
freelance journalist kk
uh reported the ban also creates a legal
right for people to sue private
companies
that collect their information in
violation of the law and seek up to a
thousand dollars in damages
for each day of violation so portland
becomes the first city to ban the use of
facial recognition
adam what do you think about this you
know i don't know what to make of this
because
when i initially think of portland i
think a very liberal city
yeah right like oregon liberal yes
democrat
um this so on the surface i hear
portland i'm thinking
liberal then as i kind of unpack this a
little bit more i'm thinking this is
more of a libertarian like don't
infringe on my rights
and then i kind of gravitate to more of
like a conservative
you know you know let me do what i want
to do don't interfere
yes so i don't know what to make of the
story is this a liberal thing is this a
libertarian thing is this a conservative
thing stay out of my bedroom stay out of
my face say that am i right i don't know
what to make of this
but um they're standing their ground
either one way or another portland to
stand it up to facial recognition i
guess this 5g is this part of that stuff
or this is a
palantir what was that volunteer i don't
think palantir is linked to this
uh but uh facial recognition i mean you
gotta
why would a private entity i get
government because for police
law enforcement but why would a private
entity want
facial recognition is it for their own
security
well no i mean you've got to realize
this whole meeting that they're having
at the house with
you with the amazon google all these
guys is selling your data
of course right right selling your data
so uh a a
very uh a big ted meeting that was that
took place 10 years ago
they said what is the best industry to
be part of to be a part of in the future
the next few decades
they said data it's all about data right
now whoever's got the most data
has the best access if you've got data
you can
re-target target you can do a lot of
things if you have the data on people
right so
i understand why private agents like why
would private enterprises want to have
uh facial recognition and government yes
i get it but
portland see here's here's the thing you
know how you sit down and you talk to
somebody
about politics like almost anybody i
talked about politics
and you say you don't ask them are you
democrat or republican you don't ask
them that
you just ask them basic questions you
say let me ask you
uh how comfortable are you sharing your
privacy with others people say what
okay how comfortable are you an
institution or an organization knowing
about your family you and your wife's
sex life
zero okay how comfortable are you about
the government or an institution knowing
exactly about all your financial
situation where you're absolutely zero
okay how comfortable are you a
organization knowing everything about
how you raise your kids how comfortable
are you okay business okay
fair enough not zero let me let me ask
you this let me
let me ask you this how comfortable are
you allowing strangers to break into
your car or your house without your
permission of course not
you're not comfortable with that yeah
are you comfortable with that yeah no
okay
okay how come if you were to choose to
live in another country
adam you got three kids you got four
kids what are one of the first things
you would consider before you want to
move into another country what would it
be what would that country need to offer
safety safety okay for your kids the
first amendment okay
first let me ask you a question if
somebody comes into your house and
decides to take stuff
out should you have the right to hit
them upside the head with a baseball bat
yeah should you have the right if not
more but but i'm asking a simple
question i'm not asking politics
if somebody breaks into your house and
they want to steal all your you know
belongings
should you have the right to own a gun
and tell them to get the hell out of
your house
should you have the right to do that yes
or no sure okay so let's just say you're
upset about
somebody that is going against you in
politics
should you have the right to call a
meeting and bring your 50 friends and
family members to your place and say
look here's what we need to do go go up
against the mayor
should you have the right to have a
meeting with 50 friends and relatives
locally
okay so this everything i'm saying okay
so let's just say you go out and you
work your tail off you work 60 hours in
a week you miss
great memories of your kids and you have
to work that one weekend maybe even
you're working on christmas weekend
because
you are in retail you have to work on
christmas right
how much of your how much of your dollar
you make are you comfortable giving to
the government
the the very least is possible how much
is that very least what are you
comfortable without getting upset
without getting irate five percent five
percent
you make a buck i'm actually being
serious you make a buck what are you
willing to give
what are you willing to give five cents
five cents what are you willing to give
adam
yeah i mean i want to pay his least
taxes give me the number what are you
willing to attempt well so what's your
question if i told you according to my
tax bracket 39 something percent no i
didn't say what your tax bracket is are
you comfortable what you're comfortable
i'm not comfortable paying [ __ ] okay
it's not about covering it but watch
this but say i come back to you and i
say okay fine you don't want to pay [ __ ]
you say no i don't want to pay [ __ ] okay
so is it fair to say that the roads are
on you right did you go to public
schools
i did so you pay for all publix your own
roads your own cops
911 so so meaning you would like to pay
some taxes
you say yes what portion of your dollar
that you work your tail off would you
like to give to me
15 flat tax fine 15 are you being
sarcastic
no i'm not okay now that you're saying
the point the point i'm trying to make
to you is i agree with the people of
portland
yeah what the hell do you mean you want
to have facial recognition
you know first of all facial recognition
everywhere now
i don't want you to do any kind of
facial recognition to me are you a spy
are we going back to these
and just the fact that it says portland
becomes the first city to ban the use of
facial recognition here's the real
question who's really
how many people are listening to the
same so if they're the first city this
means all the
other cities are recognizing my facial
based on anywhere i go
what it's to me it's not even important
it's like you don't want to use your
face id anymore
and and by the way i know some people
are going to be like well pat you know
portland is this and portland is that
i've been to portland
believe me i know what portland's like i
had an office in portland in 2010.
i'd go to portland every other month i
had to go to portland in 2000 yeah
regularly
and it's it's definitely weird it's
qualified i've never been to portland
what's going on what's going on in the
northwest i've been very important i've
never been to austin have you ever been
to austin austin is weird that's what
they're about
austin's got nothing on portland really
qualified weird wow
qualified weird they take it to whole
different level portland but i get along
with weird i don't have a problem with
the people i get along with weird you
get along with everyone
i get along with everybody but the point
i'm trying to make to you is how is the
weirdest city in america today banning
facial recognition
that's that was my point initially i
don't know if they're liberal what do
you think about it
so do you think other people are going
to do it as well yeah i think so as well
obviously like uh the facial recognition
on an iphone
isn't included because that's something
you you will willingly
comply to open up your iphone yeah
guy you might need a mic buddy yeah very
soon very soon he'll get a mic that'll
be a promotion for that guy yeah
okay all right so there you have it with
these uh uh uh so
so let's talk about the next company a
company that adam
has never gone to because adam uh is
team coach
adam's team coach adam has never bought
one of his girls a louis vuitton bag oh
okay
never i wish i were for a controller
yeah so adam is a team coach
uh adam is team michael kors on discount
on thursdays
oh i wish that my lady friends would
take a question
you have no idea how many arguments i've
had over person
over personally yeah but let's see let's
get to the topic before i go
hold it together hold it together so
tiffany sues
louis vuitton yesterday u.s jeweler
tiffany sued french luxury giant louis
vuitton in delaware after louis vuitton
tried to back out of a 16.2 billion
acquisition of tiffany
amongst other things that in the light
of the threat of heavy additional
tariffs upon french goods by the us
france's ministry of europe and foreign
affairs recommended
a letter that louis vuitton delays
proposed acquisition
acquisition of tiffany until after
january
2021 tiffany itself has also backed
louis vuitton to postpone the closing of
the merger to december 31st however
under the terms of the merger agreement
signed by louis vuitton and tiffany
november of 2019 and closing cannot be
extended until
beyond november 24 2020 louis vuitton uh
said its board has decided to adhere to
the conditions of the agreement
what do you think about this whole thing
between tiffany and louis vuitton since
you have a special place in
you know louis vuitton's louis vuitton
has a special place in your heart
why don't you tell us what you think the
best part of this story is how you
pronounce it oh my god
french pantry oh my goodness
um so let's just unpack this for a
second
lvmh louis vuitton moet hennessy
do you know what brands this company
owns let's just let's just talk about
uh lvmh louis vuitton mo at hennessey
it's owned by
bernard al-no your french friend you
know what number he is in the world
rankings of wealth interesting i don't
know number three
really number three you got besos
uh you got uh you got gates
and you have arno this guy number three
france
right and then you're thinking what i
mean so let's just
what what brands does lvmh own let's
just
luxury brands don perrion moen hedesi
hello bulgari sephora where all my girls
like to get makeup
givenchy dior fendi dkny
the list goes on and on they own a lot
of luxury at all wow
so um unfortunately i've had to buy a
lot of those types of gifts for lady
friends
buy and drink them yeah buy and drink
them um
whatever this lawsuit is i i've i
couldn't even read this i'm like i just
spent so much stupid money
so the thing about me my friends
everyone out there i don't mind spending
money on
ladies that i'm with i don't i don't buy
i don't spend anything on myself that's
my whole thing it's like
i don't have a car i bought a girl
alexis i don't i don't wear jewelry i
bought in a girl tiffany
medallion i don't you know rock anything
i've brought in a girl
uh louis handbags so i've spent a lot of
money on
these types of products um but i'm a
simple guy i'm a simple guy
so i don't know you're you're a louis
guy or what are you oh ricky's a big
louie guy
ricky's all louis oh yeah ricky's
underwears louie this guy ricky's mask
is loose
yeah rick i didn't know i didn't know
ricky that well and he put it on i
thought he was joking
he's like buddy if i'm gonna roll out
i'm running a louie
facemask buddy i'm like can you even
breathe
doesn't matter they just buy the rolls
royce as well they just bought a rolls
royce was that is that
i thought it was the ghost that they
just got on instagram yeah
they just bought it they just uh he had
the lambo announced the rose yeah he's
doing his thing so what would you take
what do you think what's your take on
this you know i
wonder what the power move is why would
yeah i get the i get the move
that the it's a it's a attacks thing
it's a it's a terror thing
but you know you're in your book is
there is there a power move here that we
haven't uh
they're just wanting to make a timely
decision based on the money
i actually don't think this is a power
but you know i just brokered a deal
yesterday and have to have to battle
about the broker in the deal was about
how to minimize taxes that's what it is
yeah i think this is purely a tax thing
and i think they got to work with them i
know this whole november 24th and give
me a break i mean if they want to do
that and you extend it for a month and a
half
to get the deal done just do january yes
but uh i also understand what it is that
if you had an agreement on
a contract and they refused to do it
they don't have to do it right
so we'll see what's going to happen we
hope it doesn't get too ugly because
both of these brands have been
historically very prestigious
and we hope they stay that way well
maybe some people hope they don't stay
that way so there's a discount for it
but it is what it is i think some of the
bigger questions is with everything
happening with covet around the world
the rich are getting richer the poor are
getting poorer are these brands
are they manufacturing stuff right now
and selling them i'm that's a
right are they meaning is there a market
for these brands still there's no
question there's a market for these
clients
i mean i i i happened to peek into your
conference room the other day
and there were gift bags louis vuitton
bags and
your gucci bags versace and that was
just a
weekend at the pbd house so yeah
you did give those away too we did gave
away i don't know what the number was
5000 stuff
we give a lot of stuff away but so okay
so that's that part
uh uh let's let's let's go to
amazon amazon added the ex-nsa
spy chief who presided over the edward
snowden scandal
to its board thursday it has elected
former national security agency
chief keith alexander to his board
alexander presided over the nsa
when the edward snowden's scandal broke
snowden reacted to the news of
alexander hiring to amazon sync it turns
out
hey alexa is short for hey keith
alexander which is pretty powerful
general keith alexander presided as
director national agency from 2005 to
2014 after which he founded his own
cyber security company
iron net security is this
something deeper than what it is or is
amazon just trying to protect themselves
against a cyber attack well he was the
first
general keith alexander was the first
commander of the u.s cyber command
okay so if there's anybody that knows
anything about setting up and
establishing
it's him yeah i think this is just a
smart addition to the board
you you just recruited a guy that can
provide a lot of value relationships
and insights of people are trying to
come after your company are you reading
into this adam or no that's
no any time that the word general is in
the sentence i just throw it over to sao
paulo
you take this one matt uh general mattis
general keith alexander
you know i i the the story that i have
here is
regarding edward snowden and this is
where my problem with the media
is edward snowden a good guy is he a bad
guy
is he anti-american is he pro-american
this guy i don't know this guy's name
has been out there for so long
yeah he he just he's a guy that just
doesn't want to be infringed on he wants
his privacy
right just leave me leave it that's what
it would seem and he was the um
why can't i think of the word the uh
when you when you whistleblower thank
you kai
whistleblower of everything that was
happening um this was in
during uh mid to mid you know
2010 i want to say maybe before that
point is
this edwin snowden guy edward snowden
guy seems like a legit guy but the media
has portrayed him to be sort of a
bad guy i mean what's your take on
snowden i mean who did he expose
give me the name of who he exposed
expose the government okay
who who was in the government when he
exposed him i want to say bush
okay who else did he expose
who else did snowden expose nsa who else
i mean obama who i don't know he was
doing
everybody hillary everybody put it out
there yes right and it was
everybody okay so when they do that you
know you're gonna have the government
that's gonna call the media saying hey
listen
you guys gotta kind of uh cut this part
out and this is a little bit too much
and uh
you know i'm not uh happy about this and
you know sometimes like what he's saying
hiring somebody like that
you know you're really hiring his
rolodex
amazon is hiring keith alexander's
rolodex it's it's the contact
you talk about from 2005 to 2014 that's
nearly 10 years
okay what's his rolodex look like in the
space of cyber security and is that the
rolodex that
jeff bezos wants of course of course he
wants that he wants that roller deck so
he wants to call those contacts that he
has
with amazon i think you know on basil's
move good for him for getting it
i also understand why the media would
turn this into a story it's probably
something you got to write about
uh because it's always interesting when
things like this takes place
like when huawei when when a uk
in one of the scenarios hired somebody a
former executive from huawei
a little bit strange when you get some
of these companies that are hiring
former cyber security from china
i mean this happened just last year you
got to pay attention to it but i don't
think it goes
much more than that with basically are
you a snowden
fan anti-snowden i am neutral i am
taking on i am
all for anybody that whistle blows on
the government who's trying to
manipulate against the people what i'm
not against
is when whistleblowers uh whistle blow
against a country's
plan of attack or strategy i don't think
that's healthy for the people because
the enemy knows what they're going to do
next
but if you're going to whistleblow
somebody on what they did 10 20 30
years ago or even in emails when you
know clinton or some of that stuff
i'm with that we need to know what's
going on there and the manipulation part
of it so
yes i'm with that part so uh uh next
next
since we're talking about this by the
way we're talking about the uh
nsa and uh uh you know if there's any
kind of link with some of these other
countries what they're doing with a
snowden or whistleblower
um a documentary was sent my way
okay and the documentary is titled
covert cash
i don't know if you've seen it or not i
haven't seen it did i
you said i sent it to you if you get a
text from pat at midnight on a tuesday
saying watch this you're freaking
watching yeah we all get
me kai and mario sorry mario kai and i
let me use proper english
text that i watch it immediately what
did you think about
watches first of all why don't you tell
people who are listening to this
okay what was the documentary about so
um
i'll try to do it justice the
documentary was basically
about i said she was the lead person
main
storyteller here covert cash what u.s
universities don't want you to know
about their foreign funding so
let's talk about foreign funding and
they highlighted basically a handful of
countries number one
china number two russia number three
saudi
number four qatar amongst a handful of
other countries
that are basically it's a pay-for-play
thing kai used a great
word prostitution where these
universities are accepting
a boatload of cash to
you know indoctrinate um
their philosophies their philosophy so
the confucius school
china sets up confucius schools in a
certain
so it's sort of like soft power right if
anything we've learned about china's
they're not
going to go attack you they're going to
do they're going to sort of
uh soft power their way weasel their way
in
whisper their way in to say things about
you but it was actually shocking how
much these universities would accept
and then when chyna says don't say
nothing bad about us they say yes sir
yes sir to the point where what i think
the story was
um oh they they talk about uh the the
leader of
saudi arabia uh m what is it mbs
muhammad bill salman
uh he goes around to these universities
and they're just like
bowing down because he gave him you know
a couple billion bucks
so the most poignant part of this
episode
of this story was qatar
sued texas a m
for talking about certain things they
shouldn't be talking about this is a
public
university in the state of texas yeah
take them on now can get more american
than that don't get me
back in texas and they sued him to shut
the up
and talking about things you know what
texas a m did they shut their mouth
no so that was the craziest thing they
wouldn't release their records they
wouldn't talk
back it was a very very shady
pay-for-play type of move what so let me
let me give you some stats let me give
you some stats
harvard leads all u.s colleges
that's received a billion dollars from
china
wow this is from bloomberg by the way
i'm not quoting you anything else but
bloomberg and bloomberg is
bloomberg he just ran for president on
the left he said he dropped out to
support biden yeah right this is not
political stuff but at all this is not
left it's not right so
this is all about the green as i said
harvard leads u.s colleges that received
a billion dollars from china
now first of all why are you receiving a
billion dollars yeah and let's just say
you do receive a billion dollars from
china
for what if if anybody receives a
billion dollars from somebody yeah what
do you owe them yeah exactly
something what do you something right no
free lunches yeah
you own something you know so three
girls
yeah so what do you owe them you you owe
them a
favor you owe them to protect them
against what
you owe them to change the way a certain
thing is being said in schools
you know a couple weeks ago not even a
couple weeks but i think it was this
week's podcast when we talked about
how uh uh china is changing the way
you think about anything they want you
to think about them in a very positive
way the movie mulan right where they
said hey
hey uh the act main actress and jackie
chan you got to say good things about
cpc
uh communist uh what is it ccp yeah uh
china come as part of why would i say
good things about you you gotta say
goodbye
half a billion dollars say good things
okay yeah super play
but a billion dollars was given to china
then the other countries you look at was
russia
was qatar was saudi arabia iraq
pakistan palestine
syria turkey venezuela
enemies but out of all of these
countries these are all enemies you're
taking money from
what are you doing taking money from
these enemies you know
for me it becomes even more concerning
because so every university gets started
with
a good intention i think whoever starts
a university there's a good motive
behind it
you want to add your own method of
teaching you want to add your own style
and
most of these schools are named after
somebody harvard
was somebody howard somebody you know
yale yes
it's a name of somebody right that when
they went to school bring them young byu
yeah byu
lds somebody right in in utah
but uh to take money from china and now
you're gonna teach my kids a certain way
of thinking and my kids are gonna spend
more time with you and by the time
they're 18 i lose them to you
and now you own them because they're
going to say things like and we're
supposed to as parents telling our kids
what listen to your teachers
yeah listen to your teachers so your
kids are growing up saying well mom you
told me listen to your teachers
subject letters here's a question how
many who says more this watch this who
says more
do parents say more listen to the
teachers or do teachers say more listen
to your parents
no parents say listen to your teachers
parents say more listen to your teachers
teachers don't say listen to your
parents
this is a monopoly here parents are
taught to tell their kids to go listen
to the teachers but teachers are not
have to tell the kids to go listen to
their parents
so you want me for 18 years to tell my
kids listen to your teachers
yeah and then you want me to send them
to school that got a billion dollars
from china
and you want me to have china teach the
history of china from the perspective of
china that gave you a billion dollars to
say
take those three sentences out of your
textbook because we gave you a billion
dollars
wink wink or whatever nah you know what
no no i'm not i'm not good with that
uh in my mind i think there's somebody
from china that goes to that school
and edits all the material in infuses
into the curriculum what they need to
learn what they
need a sensor or need to take out that's
what i'm envisioning right now
if you take this check we're gonna have
a team of people come to your school
university
into your curriculum and here's what you
need to teach everybody that's what i'm
visualizing right now
all these countries yeah i just realized
something by the way as you were
speaking
now because obviously you're looking for
schools for your kids
in in certain places and you're always
asking what does this school believe
what's their prac what's their fault
always always what do you know about
this school yeah i'm realizing now
because they're going to be around these
teachers they're going to be around
these influential people
yeah and you want to make sure that your
kids are being taught
what they should be being taught not
what someone paid for them and their
fellow students are there being taught
the same thing let me let me say
you get uh you get airtime we see you
just so you know that he says turkey is
a uh a nation of nato mario whoever uh
we you you can keep that guy going i'm
i'm not uncomfortable with that he can
be on there this is fully fine
but uh you know a nation of uh
uh yeah no spamming police i understand
but we saw him for saying things like
that we don't want to see spamming
but turkey is a part of nato but uh
just because you're part of nato doesn't
mean you're a full-on ally ally 100
america walks very carefully with turkey
because turkey's the most powerful
has the most powerful military in the
middle east and you have to be good with
them this is why the armenian genocide
hasn't become official by the white
house
but it did by congress and senate
because you have to be very careful with
turkey because u.s still owns three
bases in turkey and if you do say
armenian genocide
erdogan has said that he's going to kick
those three bases out and america needs
those three bases and so
there's a whole story behind it i don't
want to get a little bit more technical
but i understand
that turkey is a part of nato what's the
what's the relationship between turkey
and iran for uh allies
no agitators no what's that relationship
i think i think turkey kind of holds
their uh
guard with usain if you screw me i'm
gonna become a friend with the people
that are your enemies
i think that's the angle that yeah it is
it is
you got to always be careful you know
sometimes you have people that are close
to you you watch them you know the
people that work close to you but they
stay close to your enemies
i'm always worried like i have somebody
that's working with me why are you
following my enemies
yep what's your motive of following the
enemies why are you befriending the
enemies
those guys don't have a long lifespan
with me because if you're doing that
what is your motive
what are you doing here you can't play
both sides yeah what are you doing there
if you're if you're in you're in if
you're not in then
go do whatever you want to do i'm not
there this is not no dictatorship for
you to have to be here
right but uh yeah you got to be careful
you know you got to be careful what's
going on and with the school link
if anybody's listening to this if you're
a parent ask more
questions when you go interview a school
ask them like i asked the schools the
following question
uh let me ask you what do you guys say
about capitalism i asked the question
what are your thoughts on capitalism
what do you guys think about rich people
what do you think about entrepreneurs
yep
what do you think about politics how do
you think the president's doing
how do you think about this how do you
think oh yeah how do you what do you
think about the oh you know like i went
to one school and we sat down and they
said
we are known as the number one
most progressive school in all of
america and we fully believe in climate
change and going
green and we teach our young kids about
being progressive
for thirty five thousand dollars a year
yeah no i'm not going to send my kids to
your place
i'm not gonna send to my kids to your
place for them to be told how terrible
rich people are
entrepreneurs are capitalists are no
we're not going to do that i had my
daughters wear a capitalist shirt i have
a shirt it's called capitalists yeah
and we're to their high school it says
how much how much how much crap did you
get today
so nothing from the students but i got
some teachers yeah teachers
why are you wearing that shirt what's up
with that shirt why are you wearing that
shirt i remember one time we were
sitting there with aoki steve aoki you
know the dj's stereo
and nancy was wearing a shirt say i love
capitalism
and he walks in she walks in and steve
looks at her and says
i love capitalism what kind of shirt is
that she says oh we're an entrepreneur
channel
okay yeah so he was uncomfortable about
it
why is capitalism a bad word for some
people it is because capitalists are
seen by these cartoons that a lot of us
were raised on
is these big fat men who take money away
from the skinny
people that's what the cartoon
characters show you ever seen the
cartoon characters with big fat
capitalists yeah yeah the capitalist is
always painted as a big fat fat
cat or a pig yeah yeah big fat pig that
takes the money
away from everybody what are the
socialists painted as
oh loving angels you know wings uh
uh uh gabriel-esque you know
michael angels you know
so much you know you're so incredible
you know
by the way this leads me to a feud that
took place between
elon musk and reich oh here we go robert
reich
recently let me read this tweet if
you have this tweet pull it up oh you
got it okay uh
here we go there it is tesla robert
wright who
worked under uh clinton administration
he worked under
uh uh obama administration i believe and
he also worked under gerald ford we have
to say that as well because he's been
around for a long time
he's got a couple of documentaries on
income inequality and saving capitalism
yes he does
but with his saving capitalism is not
really saving no it's not really taking
shots at capitol
negative spin on capitalism so robert
reich says tesla forced all workers to
take a 10
pay cut from mid april until july in the
same period
tesla stocks skyrocketed and ceo elon
musk's network quadrupled from 25
billion to 100 billion
elon musk respond and then he says on
the bottom musk is a modern day
robber baron elon musk responds
all tesla workers also get stocks so
their compensation increased
you proportionately a modern day [ __ ]
you know you know here's a story with
this guy and they're having a battle and
i send out a tweet myself
yesterday as well if you can type in kai
robert reich
guardian just go up there and up there
top
no no go uh robert reich and guardian
robert reich guardian g-u-a
there you go the first one that came up
just press on click on that
and then go up there and type in uh uh
go up there and type in
china china it's an article click on
that one okay watch this
this is an article he wrote last year
forget china it's america's
go up a little bit it's america's own
economic system that's broken
okay so you're american apparently keep
going lower
keep going lower keep going lower look
what he says uh the american economic
system it for is focusing on maximizing
shareholder returns and it's achieving
that goal on friday the s p notched a
new all-time high but average americans
have seen no significant gains in their
incomes for
four decades adjusted for inflation
china's economic system by contrast
is focused on maximizing china the
government and it's achieving that goal
40 years ago china was still backward
and agrarian
today it's the world's second largest
economy home to the world's biggest auto
industry and some of the world's most
powerful technology companies
over the last four decades hundreds of
millions of chinese people have been
lifted out of poverty
because of capitalism because of
capitalism
that's why see you got people like this
that are in america
that are on the payroll of people from
china
they're on the payroll of people who
don't love america
back to your earlier goes back to my
thing there's a little bit more money
from yeah
let me give you some money and buy you
man if you know i had a conference call
this week
with uh on the dream team call on
tuesday and here's what i said
i said you know what kind of people
when you're when you're young and uh
even if i ask you okay when you're
younger and naive how can you be bot
so you're a woman you're attractive
let's just say you're drop dead
attractive
how is an 18 year old girl bought by a
32 year old guy how is she bot
you give me the words you probably ask
me yeah
outside of gifts how do you do it you're
at a state lottery
you're at the uh a counter of uh foot
locker girls working there
beautiful care of you that's it what do
you take care of you what what lines
give me something i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna give you all my lines
why are you working here you don't have
to work here anymore yeah you don't have
to work anymore
oh my gosh
well the one thing about all of us here
is uh the two of us actually we've only
kissed one girl in our lives yeah
yeah so
you know i didn't say it that loud
but it was showing oh yeah it was but
what's what's the line do you think
about it oh my gosh you're so beautiful
let me ask you does your man take care
of you man if i had somebody like you
i'd be focused on you 24 7.
what does he do he must take care of his
car more does he focus on his body more
i'd be focused on your body more
this kind of stuff it's ready to go
this this kind of stuff you say rod if i
were you i would do this to you you know
okay
if i was your man okay so the 18 year
old's like oh my gosh
i want to be with this guy and then you
fall for it right okay
as you age you know and couple people
screw you over
okay men and women you learn what kind
of women
you don't want to be with women realize
what kind of men they don't want to be
with
right so and then when another person
uses that same script and you fall for
it you're a qualified [ __ ]
okay because that script's been used on
you in the past before right and women
use that line as well
you know man if you were my man every
time you woke up in the morning i
wouldn't let you leave the house
yeah all this stuff i heard this live
stream
on youtube i don't know the way you say
this
you've heard my line before it says fool
me once
if you fully
rap song he plays that uh does it really
wants uh yeah you can't you can't be
fooled again you know what i'm trying to
say yeah
but i mean listen that's why he got
reelected because people just liked him
so going back shut up going back to this
as you age
if you can be bought by money and
compliments
there's character flaws there the cheap
man if you can be
bought if loyalty can be bought
through money and compliments yep
and here's what i mean by compliments
flattery
if you are so desperate for flattery and
compliments that's a stranger somebody
you don't have a deep relationship with
can come and tell you how special you
are and you
they butter you up and you fall for it
there's deep insecurities in you that
needs to be addressed
okay if somebody says oh my gosh let me
tell you and by the way
and i'm talking pure flattery from
somebody that is doesn't have a
long-term relationship with you that's
not done anything with you
that's not experience anything with you
but they tell you something like how
special you are how amazing you are
right
pvd i get that insurance industry i got
guys that insurance hey why
why don't you come work with us we have
a 100 100 contract 125 percent we'll
give you leave that
at all you know patrick doesn't know
what he's doing you'll have much much
better life over here much much easier
for you don't have to work so hard
i get that all the time yeah all the
time and our guys get it all the time
yeah
but but that's just everything so how do
we get to this message here robert reich
okay if another country wants to buy you
today how do they buy you i mean you saw
how some people try to buy us with six
hundred thousand dollars
hey come do this and come do that yeah
and by the way please understand this
i am not saying hey if a person sells
their business you are
uh what do you call it you are a uh
because we just had a conversation with
a guy yesterday that sold his business
so
you are a uh uh sellout no you're you're
you're built you build a business
somebody wants to buy it you have an
extra strategy i'm talking about
if somebody an enemy of mine called me
perfect example i got a call from one of
my enemies and he and i talked
that's the only person in the world who
says that sentence yeah i got a call
from one of my enemies yeah
and we talked about right and we spoke
let me make a phrase a competitor okay i
got you okay
i i know what you're doing and we talked
right and we talked and we had an hour
and a half conversation together
right that's another lanyard yeah right
and and and he calls me and we're having
a conversation together this person
knows my position and i
he knows who i am and he knows how my
position is with him but he calls me
every once in a while he'll call me and
he calls me and this one that we had a
very good conversation together
and he had some uh uh things he would
share with me that he was frustrated
with
so for me i naturally will give counsel
i don't give counsel
based on uh uh manipulation i don't give
counsel based on
uh uh you know trying to brainwash it to
her
i'm gonna give the council to you
because that's how i win my loyalty even
if you're my enemy
till today i have the darkest secrets
about people who have screwed me over
that no one knows about
darkest secrets about people screwed me
over that i'm not telling anybody about
my wife doesn't know about this stuff my
wife doesn't know about the darkest
secret i know about people
that i do but if i know something about
my wife's my wife needs to know because
if it has to do with my wife
but if i know something you're you're
confiding in me and you're telling me
pal let me tell you what happened with
me and xyz
i'm keeping it because i want that
reputation to be here's how pat is if
this happens with him right
he calls me and he says well you know in
the industry this is what's happening
people are leaving and people are going
here and people are going there just
you know and what do we do to you know
get people locked and i said here's
here's what i do know
i said if you take care of your people
genuinely you genuinely take care of
your people
and they leave you one it's a character
issue two you never had them in the
first place
it's that simple okay you never had them
in the first place
and it's their loss i said but if you do
you right you treat people right
you go out there and deliver on your
promises to the best of your abilities
eventually you build a reputational
marketplace and guess what people who
are mature say
marketplace is not filled with people
that keep their word
marketplace is filled with a lot of
people that are flattery marketplaces
filled with a lot of people that are
entertaining
marketplaces filled with a lot of people
that tend to tell you what you want to
hear
but the marketplace is not filled with
people that keep their word
if you find somebody that does that
you'll lock on to them right
people like him are for sale people like
him you have to be very careful with
because uh you're going after bastian an
entrepreneur
for what this guy's created jobs he's
put all these things on the line the
guy's got five kids he's spending more
time creating
his businesses that's making the world a
better place and you're upset about it
now listen i'm not sitting here saying
elon musk is jesus i'm not sitting here
saying jeff bezos is
i know jeff bezos is power plays and
what he's trying to do and all this
other stuff and i know where this guy's
at he's got these crazy imagination
things that he wants to do
but he has made the world a better place
how has robert reich make the world a
better place
and eli right and elon musk is right to
call him a [ __ ] you know why because
robert rex has never ran a business
he's never created an invention he's
never run three four business all the
same time
simultaneously right so so he's right to
colin moore because he's never been in
the trenches
of an entrepreneur robert reich
represented an organization that told
elon musk it'll take
uh a 13 billion no what is it it'll take
six billion dollars
what was the number kai six billion
dollars in 13 years
to go in space and that was nasa and
elon musk did it in
six years with less than a billion
dollars so your organization cost
god knows how many more times versus
elon musk did so elon musk saves money
you cost people money
uh uh and again i think it's important
for people to realize when a guy like
when when the job creators like here's
what i said the other day
i send out a tweet i don't know if you
can go on my twitter profile if you can
get there fast try if you can i'll just
read it off here
here's what i said okay i got to say kai
is on fire today spelling everything
correctly pulling everything off okay
there you go
right there right there i said uh job
creators
i favor we're politicians one risks
everything to start a business
and which helps create jobs for others
the other wakes up every morning finding
a way to hold job
creators hostage by threatening them
with new regulations i choose job
creators 10 out of 10 times
exactly it's that simple exactly and i
feel bad when job creators are bullied
i don't like when job creators are
bullied i don't like when entrepreneurs
are being bullied i don't like it
i don't like when that's taking place
and i think sometimes these politicians
throw their weight around just because
you can
go make somebody's life a living hell
with regulations i think sometimes we
got to protect our entrepreneurs oh
we're at 21
19. we've never been out 21-19
the podcast put a thumbs up and share
this podcast we're coming to the tail
end of it i think we got 14 minutes here
before we wrap up
uh our 10 o'clock i know you got to fly
that uh 12 o'clock to yourself as well
but let's see what also needs a favor
from you yeah and we might have to wrap
up
9.59 uh let's see what we've got here oh
let's let's uh which one do you guys
want to hit up you want to hit up
citigroup new female ceo
challenge us sure directors or germany
putting pressure on russia or hacking an
election russia iran
let's go to board challenges you want to
go to the world champion let's go to the
first time
those two stories all right so let's go
to the board challenges first and then
we'll go to the city group so
board challenge u.s firms add a black
director to board within 12 months nine
percent of fortune 500 companies
board members are blacks let me say that
one more time nine only nine percent
of fortune 500 companies board members
are black
66 percent of fortune 500 board members
are white
18 percent of fortune 500 ward members
are white women statistically 72 percent
of directors have previously board
experience and half are current
or ex-ceos per heydrich and struggle so
nine percent of board members are black
fortune 500 companies 66 percent of
white men
and 18 are white women what do you have
to say about this you know it's
interesting because i'm looking up here
the percentage the
the black population in america is 13.4
percent
so there's a large percentage there that
uh that is not
addressed in corporate america you look
at nine percent
a fortune 500 we're only looking at 500
companies
and when you're looking at this you know
uh one of the you speak about job
creators
because of the business we've created
here at pbd
i've been able to reinvest my money my
wife and i've been able to invest
into other job creators and we've
created
an investment in the company it's a
faster growing whiskey company right now
in america
ran by a black woman and it's the only
multicultural board in the liquor
industry that is run by a multicultural
board
and so when we're looking at these
things and and and saying you know what
you know i can't say hey you got to do
this you got to do that the only thing i
can say
listen we we need to take charge on our
own and control what we can control
and you call the south where it needs to
be called out and address the things
that
need to address but at the same time the
challenge also is within us
let's us create the businesses to let's
create us the next fortune 500 companies
so therefore we can import appoint our
boards and i know it's going to take a
minute
but uh you know that's why podcasts like
this exist that's why the information
and
the awareness needs to to to create but
i think
corporate america can do a lot better uh
but
you're looking at two uh multicultural
guys here with no college degrees
creating a company
um that's our answer you know it's a
that's uh that's how we go about
our business that's how we handle i
don't what do you say about that
you know instinctually just how i am
when i see
only nine percent of uh fortune 500
board members are like i said this is
[ __ ] ridiculous come on
we got to do better than this like
that's what i have in my heart but i've
realized
don't just jump to conclusions start
looking at some numbers
matt brought up a great stat 13
of america is black okay uh
17 latinos 61 white
um five percent asian uh
two percent multi-cultural
multi-uh racial one percent indian
a lot of uh amazing filipino people here
as well i don't know where they are yeah
where they're at they're rising up
they're so they're rising up so they're
in the hospital
instinctually what's my point
instinctually i'm thinking we got to do
better we got to do better
so i guess my answer would be we need to
do at least four percent better we need
to
at least mirror what's in the population
so
two points here number one i'm all for
hiring the best person for the job
correct right so like i know that we've
talked about when biden sort of
uh pigeonholed himself where he's like
i'm going to select a black female
okay respect i feel you on that i'm good
with that
but is that the best person for the job
so i'm sort of conflicted i want you to
hire the best person for the job
but at the same time i'm all for giving
people a shot
so there's been many years where i'm
sure that it was way less than nine
percent that
african americans were on the board of a
500 uh fortune 500 company i'm sure
10 years ago it was 5 and i'm sure 25
years ago it was
2 so as long as we're doing better and
as long as that we're in inclusive
society but as long as
it's still the best person for the job
okay so i got some data for you
how about that is that okay with you if
we do some data i like data okay i got
data for you here's my data for you i
understand what both of you guys are
saying and i'm with you
but here's what i did um i went
online and i got the following
percentage so the percentage you got is
what percentage of americans are
african-american which is 13.4 percent
right what percentage are latinos 18.5
percent
and then what percentage are white
population-wise there's roughly 42
million
african americans in america there's
roughly 52 million hispanics
and there's roughly 234 million whites
so let's do
whites and blacks specifically because
we're not talking hispanics here so
there's total
234 million whites in america 41 million
42 million blacks in america
okay white blacks per uh population
total
then when i pull up the data here from
uh the government nces.ed.gov
it says degrees conferred by race and
ethnicity oh let's
check this out this is okay so this is
pretty interesting yeah so now
you go to bachelor's degree for whites
uh uh for whites percentage-wise versus
uh
blacks what degree what percentage get
degrees right
uh uh total population in america
uh uh uh white's uh 1.21 million
uh is the degree a college degree yeah
this is during that year
uh blacks was 192 000 okay for
that specific academic year so whites to
blacks was
six plus times more by the way latinos
got more bachelor degrees than african
americans latinos was 217
000 versus african americans 190 2 000
which is not
a big deal because there are more
latinos than hispanics than african
americans so that part makes sense
what are the asian numbers of this show
the asian numbers those numbers are
usually off the chain the asian numbers
are not asian numbers right there 133
actually lower than latinos and blacks
but the population of asians is not that
big
right yeah so look here's where i'm
going with this here's why i'm going
with this
if you want to be in the board of a
fortune 500 company what do most
board members have in common they have
degrees and they went to fancy schools
and they have experience i'm not on a
fortune 500 company
board and i don't have a four-year
degree i don't have a two-year degree
so it has also a lot to do with hiring
qualified people
that go and get degrees if you want to
be on a board you got to hire a
qualified person
go beyond the board that has to do with
uh
having the right education sheena sits
on our chairman of the board right your
wife is a chairman of the board of the
field
right prior to you guys getting married
what was sheena she was a salesperson
for a striker and she got a college
degree at university of pitt
university at a pit and she she was a
softball player she played pro she got a
full ride scholarship she was a rock
star right
but she's got a degree from university
pitt right
and she's half white half black
and she's the chairman of the board we
so you have a black
single mother you know but has a degree
that brings value she's the chairman of
the board it's not just anybody so
i think these numbers are obviously you
sit there and say well we have to
because it's
13.4 we have to have 13.4 percent of all
the board members being black you can't
say that it's got to be
the percentage being made based on how
many are getting degrees that are
getting results it's not just about
color
you know at our home office if somebody
comes here they would say we
discriminate
why do we discriminate we have more
black workers here than any other
ethnicity
somebody could say we discriminated
somebody could say well pat you're
racist again
against white people you have more
blacks than whites here it's not about
that it's very uncomfortable i'm the
only white person that's going on right
but when i when you look at the
environment all i'm saying to you
baby all i'm saying to you is in many
circumstances
i do agree nike has to have black board
members on there because their product
is considered their products are
athletes nfl
nba yes that does make sense but they
also have to have soccer because now
they're getting more into the soccer
side
i think adidas needs to get uh uh uh uh
kanye west under i do agree with that
and if he bought gap he needs to be on
there as well
there needs to be an element of that
that there needs to be some cleaning up
to do
but i don't think it's as crazy and as
astronomically
oh my gosh america is a racist nation
they don't want any black board members
i don't agree with that either i'm just
curious
how much of the those college degrees
are actually from ivy league schools
that are board members i wonder what the
potential breakdown of that well you
know
if you went to xyz texas a m versus
harvard
does that does have any players depends
on the state depends on the state so if
a company is a texas
uh company they're gonna want texas
universities to be there it's a lot of
pride in texas
they want texas universities to be there
but uh uh if you look at private equity
for example the private equity world
yeah
you you saw yesterday when you and i and
we're having a meeting together
all the private equity guys right now
we're dealing with there are ivy leagues
all of them are ivy league
all of them the golden ticket he said
yeah it's the golden you get you get
an ivy league degree you go become a
private equity guy you do deals with
private equity guys are from ivy you're
making your two to ten million dollar
your income
crazy and private equity yeah dartmouth
you know
but if you went to a if you went to an
elite school like me glendale community
college
big time thanks guys i won't tell you
guys when you go to glendale community
college and you have the kind of
uh letters that i got letters of
acceptance yeah when i got my letter of
acceptance from gcc i mean it was a
celebration
we went to sizzlers we celebrated the
ponderosa
man it was celebration time when i got
my letter of acceptance from gcc
so now let's talk about citigroup cause
i'm assuming you got something to say
about our friend here at citigroup city
group's new female ceo first woman
ceo of big wall street bank wall street
giant city announced thursday that it's
ceo michael corbett will retire after an
eight year tenure at csco he'll be
replaced by jane fraser where'd she go
to school
okay put her in the comments i got it
because she went to harvard
no kidding she went to talk about she
worked for goldman for a while
she worked for uh mckinsey is that the
consulting group
the biggest one right so she has
pedigree and she has a track record
so it's good for her this woman jane
frazier
is a certified g and um
this is this is not a small story by the
way you may think
of the major banks in america this is
the first female ceo
ever yeah ever of a major wall street
bank
jane frazier so this is historic i think
she
i think this is a um a wonderful
role model for women i don't have
daughters i know that you have a
daughter i know that you have daughters
yes
um i think if they want to be
entrepreneurs and they want to be in the
business world and they want to succeed
they're going to might be saying well
what ceos have run major banks yeah well
take a look at jane over here yeah well
yeah well
in addition to pamela young with the
pamela yellen the former you know fed
reserve
you know chairman too as well yeah when
you're looking at this stat you know
i remember the um there was a study 2010
that 60
of all wealth in america shifted into
the control of women
in 2010. yeah i was doing seminars and
doing something about that it's funny
because some guy said well shoot my
when i got married my wealth my house
shifted into in 1995
2010. but more women today are
graduating colleges and men
more women today are in politics mormon
today nonprofit for-profit organizations
running executive directors of
companies ceos of companies uh but to
see finally now
a woman lead a bank breaking the good
old boy circle
and now a woman has uh you know his
influence him because listen in my house
pb
in your house i don't have a very
strange conversation with with uh
jennifer about money but in the clients
that we serve
you know a good majority of the
conversation of kitchen table
conversations is i'm the man of the
house i'm a man of house
right babe
as a release to money right i make
financial decisions
right babe it's it's a
it's an interesting conversation i mean
your wife is cio
of people of operations vp of operations
your wife is chairman chairwoman of the
board you guys are married to certified
g's
so it's you know the ladies are getting
there i will tell you this
uh i am very surprised that's this the
first woman
yeah i'm very surprised by the fact that
because women
don't get the degrees women go uh get
educated you know women take education
very seriously so i'm surprised that
part's not taking place yet but
congratulations to jane
uh uh shout out to her for doing what
she does by the way for those of you
guys that are watching this
today's podcast a couple things we're
coming to the end here if you haven't
yet subscribed to the channel please do
so put that alert button as well click
on that as well
and put a thumbs up and if you enjoyed
our brother here
matt zappala that joined us uh kai if
you can put
his channel oh seven figure squad in the
comments section you can
uh matt's got his own channel as well
mario's already done it uh
mario do it again if you can for people
you can go follow matt matt's content
uh we'll put his instagram account
that's one of the coolest cats you'll
ever meet in your life
uh hands down one of the coolest cats
you'll ever meet in your life but if you
do hang out with them i do want to
prepare you will have a cigar if you
hang out with them there's no question
about or two
or two that's true or shout out to
chamber having said that do we have the
dates for the next one yet
kai is it going to be next tuesday or
wednesday
is it tuesday next tuesday eight o'clock
we'll be back at it again have a great
weekend
everybody take care bye bye
bye bye bye
you